Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Madame, my ears have been so deafened, and my understanding so grieved, and my heart so affrighted to hear the dreadful news of the abominable murder of your mad husband and my slain cousin, that I scarcely have the wits to write about it. I cannot dissemble that I am more sorrowful for you than for him. Oh, madam, I would not do the office of faithful cousin or affectionate friend if I studied rather to please your ears than employed myself in preserving your honor. I will not at all dissemble what most people are talking about, which is that you will
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。夫人，听到您那发狂的丈夫、我被杀害的表弟遭遇令人发指的谋杀这一噩耗，我的耳朵为之震聋，我的理解力为之痛心，我的心脏为之惊恐，以至于我几乎没有心思来书写此事。我无法掩饰，我为您感到的悲伤远甚于为他。哦，夫人，如果我只求取悦您的耳朵，却不用心维护您的荣誉，那我便没有尽到忠实表亲或深情朋友的职责。我绝不会掩饰大多数人正在谈论的事情，那就是您将
look through your fingers at the revenging of this deed, and that you do not take measures that touch those who have done as you wished, as if the thing had been entrusted in a way that the murderers felt assurance in doing it. I exhort you, I counsel you, and I beseech you to take this thing so much to heart that you will not fear to touch even him whom you have nearest to you if the thing touches him, and that no persuasion will prevent you from making an example out of this to the world, that you are both a noble princess and a loyal wife.
对这桩行径的复仇睁一只眼闭一只眼，并且您没有采取针对那些按您意愿行事之人的措施，就好像此事已被委託，使得凶手们在行凶时感到十拿九稳。我劝诫您，我奉劝您，我恳求您将此事深记于心，以至于即便触及与您最亲近的人，如果事情牵涉到他，您也敢于触及，并且没有任何劝说能阻止您以此向世人树立榜样——证明您既是一位高贵的王后，又是一位忠诚的妻子。
Praying the Creator to give you the grace to recognize this traitor and protect yourself from him as from the ministers of Satan with my very heartfelt recommendations to you very dear sister. So that is a letter Tom written by Elizabeth the first on the 24th of February 1567. She's writing to Mary Queen of Scots. She is writing following the murder two weeks previously of Mary's husband and Elizabeth's cousin. Scotland's leading cock chick, I believe is the technical term, Lord Darnley. So this is an amazing document making all kinds of slightly passive aggressive allegations
祈求造物主赐予您恩典，认出这位叛徒并防范他，如同防范撒旦的使者一般，并致以我最诚挚的问候，给您，我最亲爱的姐姐。好了，汤姆，这是一封由伊丽莎白一世于 1567 年 2 月 24 日写下的信。她写信的对象是苏格兰女王玛丽。她是在玛丽的丈夫、伊丽莎白的表弟——苏格兰首席花花公子（我猜这是专业术语）达恩利勋爵在两周前被谋杀后写下这封信的。所以这是一份惊人的文件，包含了各种略带被动攻击性的指控
and it's a document that led Antonia Fraser in her wonderful book about Mary Queen of Scots to describe the murder of Lord Darnley as the most debatable as well as surely the most worked over murder in history. Now we always love a murder and we love in particular a Scottish murder. A murder? Yeah, just give us the outline of the crime before we get going. So we've done JFK and I guess probably that would be the most celebrated murder in history, but it hasn't been around for centuries and centuries like this one has. Antonio Fraser is absolutely right. This is a murder people have been going over for
正是这份文件，让安东尼娅·弗雷泽（Antonia Fraser）在她那本关于苏格兰女王玛丽的精彩著作中，将达恩利勋爵的谋杀案描述为历史上最具争议、也绝对是被人研究得最透彻的谋杀案。现在，我们一向热爱谋杀案，尤其是苏格兰谋杀案。谋杀案？对，在我们开始之前，先给我们讲讲这起犯罪的概要吧。我们已经讲过肯尼迪遇刺案，我想那可能是历史上最著名的谋杀案，但它不像这桩谋杀案这样流传了几个世纪之久。安东尼娅·弗雷泽说得完全没错。这是一起人们研究了
century after century after century. And I think that the barest outline of the crime makes clear why. So at 2am on the 10th of February, 1567, the house on the edge of Edinburgh where Lord Darnley, so Mary Queen of Scots husband, had been staying was blown to smithereens, blown sky high. Strangely, however, Darnley had not perished in this explosion. Instead, he and his valet were found without any marks of injury in a nearby garden. They had been laid out very neatly and next to them was a chair, a rope and a thick fur cloak. So all the elements of an astonishing murder mystery.
一个世纪又一个世纪又一个世纪的谋杀案。我认为这起犯罪的最简要概述清楚地说明了原因。2月10日凌晨2点，在爱丁堡边缘的一座房子里，达恩利勋爵（也就是苏格兰女王玛丽的丈夫）当时就住在那儿，整栋房子被炸成了碎片，被炸上了天。然而奇怪的是，达恩利并没有在这场爆炸中丧生。相反，他和他的贴身随从在附近的一个花园里被发现，身上没有任何受伤的痕迹。他们被摆放得非常整齐，旁边放着一把椅子、一根绳子和一件厚重的皮大衣。所有这些都是一个令人惊叹的谋杀悬案的元素。
Agatha Christie style. Very. So some obvious questions. Who killed Darnley? How did they kill him? Where did they kill him? And what is going on with the chair and the rope and fur cloak? But of course, the most sensitive question of all is the one that Elizabeth I in that
阿加莎·克里斯蒂风格。非常像。所以有一些显而易见的问题。谁杀了达恩利？他们是如何杀他的？他们在哪里杀他的？椅子、绳子和皮大衣是怎么回事？但当然，最敏感的问题是伊丽莎白一世在其
letter you read has directly fixed on, which is, you know, is Mary complicit in the murder? Because Elizabeth says, this is what people are saying and you have to take steps to ensure, you know, that this mud doesn't stick. Another specific point that Elizabeth is making in that letter, she is hinting at the gossip that Mary had not only planned the murder, but had done so in association with one particular accomplice who Elizabeth doesn't name in her letter, but describes as being like a minister of Satan. And who Elizabeth is alluding to, we will come to in due course, because we're going to be doing a deep dive into the murder and then trying to solve the riddle of what happened.
你读的那封信中直接指出的问题，也就是，你知道的，玛丽是否是谋杀的同谋？因为伊丽莎白说，这就是人们在议论的，你必须采取措施确保，你知道的，这些脏水不会泼在你身上。伊丽莎白在那封信中提出的另一个具体观点是，她暗示了民间的八卦，即玛丽不仅策划了谋杀，而且是与一个特定的同谋联合策划的，伊丽莎白在信中没有指名道姓，但将其描述得像个撒旦的使者。至于伊丽莎白暗指的是谁，我们稍后自有分晓，因为我们将深入剖析这起谋杀案，然后试图解开事件真相的谜团。
But just to emphasize, what Elizabeth is doing in that letter is echoing claims and counterclaims that are already raging like a live fire in Scotland and within only a few months will plunge the entire kingdom into civil war and massive spoiler alert, it will ultimately result in the downfall of Mary, her imprisonment, her forced abdication, her flight to England, and I suppose in the very long run, her execution at Fothering A. So that argument about did Mary do it has raged for well for centuries effectively hasn't it and you made the point in your notes Tom that the two great books were two of the great books about Mary
但需要强调的是，伊丽莎白在那封信中所做的，是在呼应苏格兰境内已经如烈火般燃起的种种指控与反指控，这些指控在短短几个月内就会将整个王国卷入内战，而且剧烈剧透警告，它最终将导致玛丽的垮台、她的被捕、她被迫退位、她逃往英国，我想从长远来看，她在富瑟林盖（Fotheringhay）被处决。所以关于玛丽到底有没有干这事的争论实际上已经持续了几个世纪了，对吧？你在笔记中提到了这一点，汤姆，关于玛丽女王的两本伟大的著作，我的意思是，有很多非常好的书，但其中一本是安东尼娅·弗雷泽写的，安东尼娅·弗雷泽认为玛丽绝对是一个绝顶聪明的人，绝不可能做出这种事，对吧？她那颗柔软的心、对流血的恐惧、对仁慈的倾向。我的意思是，炸死她的丈夫，然后用一种非常巴洛克的方式在花园里谋杀他，是玛丽最不可能做的事。另一方面，你在本系列中经常提到的人，珍妮·沃莫尔德（Jenny Wormald），早期近代苏格兰的伟大历史学家，她绝对鄙视苏格兰女王玛丽。
Queen of Scots I mean there are multiple very good books but one of them Antonia Fraser's Antonia Fraser thinks that Mary is absolutely a brilliant person who would never have done it doesn't she that soft heart that horror of bloodshed, that inclination towards mercy. I mean, blowing up her husband and then murdering him in a very baroque way in a garden is the last thing that Mary would have done. On the other hand, somebody you've mentioned a lot in this series, Jenny Wormald, great historian of early modern Scotland, she absolutely despises Mary Queen of Scots.
如果有机会插上一刀，她绝不会放过。是的。她基本上说，如果她没有谋杀达恩利，她就是——我引用原话——“爱丁堡政治圈子里唯二对（或几乎唯一一个对）此一无所知的人”。所以基本上，这让她显得更糟。如果她没有谋杀他，反而比她谋杀了还要糟糕。是的，基本上如此。我的意思是，这两本书在某种程度上阐明了非常两极分化的立场。
If there's a chance to stick the dagger in, she'll take it. Yeah. And she basically says if she didn't murder Darnley, she was, and I quote, almost the only member of Edinburgh's political society who knew nothing about it. So basically it reflects it even more badly on her. If she didn't murder him, then if she did. Yeah, essentially. I mean, those two books kind of articulate the very polarized position.
但自从这两本书问世以来，关于达恩利谋杀案的第三项研究出炉了，我认为它为这起案件提供了一个解决方案——如果不能算完全确凿的话，因为你知道，在经历了这么长时间的跨度之后，要做到这一点很难。但我认为，这是我们所能得到的、最接近确凿真相的解决方案。这是约翰·盖伊（John Guy）的玛丽传记《我的心属于我自己》（My Heart is My Own）中的记述，该书出版于2004年，也是西尔莎·罗南（Saoirse Ronan）电影的灵感来源。而盖伊所做的——他是一位才华横溢的都铎王朝和16世纪整体历史学者——
But since they were written, a third study of Darnley's murder has come out, which I think provides a solution to the crime that if not exactly definitive because, you know, at the distance of however long it is, it's hard to do that. But I think it is as definitive a solution as we are likely to get. And this is an account in John Guy's biography of Mary, My Heart is My Own, which was published in 2004 and was the inspiration for the Saoirse Ronan film. And what Guy did, he's a brilliant scholar of the Tudors and 16th century more generally, And he has gone back and looked at all the original documents in a way that hadn't been done before. I mean, amazing to think of it. And most of
他回过头来，以一种前所未有的方式查阅了所有原始档案文件。我的意思是，想一想这真令人惊叹。而这些文件大多是
these documents are English reports written chiefly to Cecil. In the Victorian period, they were collected and kind of bunged into those, you know, the kind of enormous, vast leather bound volumes that Victorian archivists absolutely loved lots of them were miscatalogged Misinterpreted and the result of that has been that their provenance has often been obscured the dates in which they were written certain key texts have been overlooked and so Guy has done the hard yards and We reap the benefits right because essentially we will be drawing very heavily on the guy's work for our account of Darnley's murder. So before we get into the murder, Tom, let's set the scene a little bit. We ended last time, Mary has given birth to Lord Darnley's son.
英国的报告，主要写给塞西尔（Cecil）。在维多利亚时期，它们被收集并塞进那些你知道的、维多利亚时代的档案管理员绝对喜爱的巨大厚重的皮革装帧卷册里，其中许多文件都被错误地编目、误解了，其结果就是它们的出处常常被掩盖，它们被撰写的日期、某些关键文本被忽视了，所以盖伊下了苦功夫，而我们收获了成果，对吧？因为本质上，我们在讲述达恩利谋杀案时将非常严重地依赖盖伊的研究成果。所以在我们进入谋杀案本身之前，汤姆，让我们先铺垫一下背景。我们上一次结束时，玛丽刚刚生下了达恩利勋爵的儿子。
So I'm guessing most people will have heard the previous episodes in this series. So Mary, Queen of Scots, slightly beleaguered, Lord Darnley, an absolutely terrible man. You described him as one of the worst men we've ever talked about, I think. No, I didn't say that. So he's not one of the worst men as in kind of Himmler. Right. He's not like that. It's not in Himmler's league.
所以我猜大多数人都听过本系列前面的剧集了。所以，苏格兰女王玛丽处境稍显艰难，达恩利勋爵则是一个绝对糟糕透顶的男人。你曾把他描述为我们谈论过的最糟糕的男人之一，我想是这样的。不，我没那么说。所以他不是那种像希姆莱一样最糟糕的男人。对。他不是那种类型的。他不在希姆莱那个级别。
Oh my gosh. That's high praise. But he's kind of like the worst kind of person that you'd meet at a university disco at St Andrews. Yeah. Red trousers. You said, you know, cock St. Andrews. Yeah, red trousers. You said, you know, cock chick. Yeah. That's what he is.
哦天哪。这真是极高的评价。但他的那种坏，就像你在圣安德鲁斯大学迪斯科舞厅里能遇到的最糟糕的那种人。是的。红色长裤。你说过，你知道，花花公子。圣安德鲁斯。是的，红色长裤。你说过，你知道，花花公子。是的。他就是那样的人。
Probably the biggest cock chick in British history. By the way, that's not us being rude. That's Scottish. That's a Scottish source, right? Yeah. That's authentic 16th century slang. Yeah. So anyway, Mary has given birth to his son, the future James the Sixth of Scotland, big
可能是英国历史上最大的花花公子。顺便说一句，这不是我们在粗鲁无礼。这是苏格兰话。这是苏格兰的原始出处，对吧？是的。这是地道的16世纪俚语。是的。所以无论如何，玛丽生下了他的儿子，未来的苏格兰国王詹姆斯六世，他是《历史的其余部分》的超级粉丝，舌头太大塞不进嘴里，非常喜欢女巫。她做到了。她生下了他。当时爱丁堡城堡戒备森严。原因在于，在詹姆斯出生前三个月，她的秘书、那个意大利人大卫·里佐（David Rizzio），在荷里路德宫（Holyrood）她自己的私人房间里，在荒唐的情况下被谋杀了。而阴谋策划者包括她的总理——一个阴险狡诈、类似于马基雅维利式的人物，名叫莫顿伯爵（Earl of Morton）。
friend of the rest of his history, tongue too big for his mouth, loves a witch. And she's done that. She gave birth to him. It was maximum security in Edinburgh Castle. And the reason for that was that three months before the birth of James, her secretary, David Rizzo, the Italian bloke, had been murdered in Holyrood in her private quarters in ludicrous circumstances. And the conspirators had included her chancellor, who's this sinister and sort of conspiratorial Machiavelle called the Earl of Morton.
还有她的国务大臣威廉·梅特兰（William Maitland），然后达恩利勋爵，她自己的丈夫，也参与其中。提醒一下我们自己，她用不同的方式处理了他们的问题。她把莫顿和所有那些家伙实际上流放到了英国，并没收了他们的土地。梅特兰失宠了，因为他没有实际参与谋杀。所以他的惩罚没那么严厉。至于达恩利，我的意思是，这太疯狂了。
There's her secretary of state, William Maitland, and then Lord Darnley, her own husband, has been in on it. And just to remind ourselves, she dealt with them in different ways. She'd say Morton, all of those guys, she'd exiled effectively to England and she'd confiscated their lands. Maitland has been disgraced because he didn't take part in the actual murder. So his punishment is not as harsh. And Darnley, I mean, this is bonkers.
她基本上利用了女性的温柔手段来劝说他倒戈。她向他许诺可以进入她的卧室和接近她本人等等，所以对玛丽来说一切都是甜言蜜语和生活美满，她赢得了这场胜利，还是说她没有？或者她没有？我的意思是，她面临的关键问题是达恩利依然是个彻头彻尾的噩梦。你知道的，他是一个极度危险的定时炸弹。而且在个人行为上，他也很糟糕。他对她非常非常不尊重，简直是个可怕的人。
She basically used her feminine wiles To persuade him to change sides. She promised him access to her bed chamber and her person anyway So all sweetness and life for mary she's won the day or has she or has she? I mean the key problem she faces is that Darnley remains a complete nightmare. You know, he's a massive loose cannon. And also in his personal behavior, he's terrible. He is very, very disrespectful to her, just a kind of awful person.
举个例子，在八月份——到这个时候，玛丽已经从分娩中恢复过来，她和达恩利想去打猎，他们去了边境中心一个叫特拉奎尔庄园（Traquair House）的地方，这是一个非常著名的狩猎场。但结果却是一场灾难，因为实际上鹿正在消失。树林开始被砍伐。根本没有足够的猎物让达恩利好好享受一次打猎的乐趣。
So an example of this is that in August, so by now, Mary has recovered from childbirth, she and Darnley, they want to go hunting and they go to a place called Tracker House in the Borders Center, of very famous hunting ground. But it turns out to be a disaster because actually the deer are vanishing. The woods are starting to be chopped down. There isn't enough for Darnley to enjoy a good hunt.
他对此非常生气，有一天晚上他喝得烂醉如泥。我的意思是，他总是喝醉，但这次他是真的醉得厉害。他向玛丽俯身说道：“我们明天要去他妈的，你知道的，我们要去打鹿，你他妈的也得一块儿去，对吧？”玛丽不想去。她在他的耳边低声说了一个戏剧性的消息。她说她觉得自己可能又怀孕了。而达恩利根本不在乎。他在大厅里把这件事向所有人公之于众。他说：“没关系，如果我们失去这个，我们还可以再造一个。”而特拉奎尔勋爵，也就是他的主人，如果失去这个，我们还可以再造一个。
And he gets very cross about this and one night he just gets spectacularly drunk. I mean he's always drunk but this time he's really badly drunk. And he leans over to Mary and says, we're going to go bloody, you know, we're going to go hunt deer tomorrow and you're bloody well going to come, right? And Mary doesn't want to do it. And she whispers in his ear dramatic news. She says she thinks that she may be pregnant again. And Darnley doesn't care. He reveals this to everyone in the hall. He says, nevermind, if we lose this one, we shall make another one. And the Lord of Trekei, his host, if we lose this one, we shall make another.
而特拉奎尔勋爵，也就是他的主人，对此感到震惊并斥责了他，告诉他这种说话方式不像个基督徒。而达恩利当着特拉奎尔勋爵的面打了个响指。难道我们在母马怀着小马时就不能好好使唤它吗？这在特拉奎尔勋爵、玛丽的随从以及玛丽本人那里引起了极其恶劣的反响。她似乎对此感到非常冒犯，以至于中断了假期并提前离开。她完全没做错。是的，我想她是对的。是的。
And the Lord of Trakai, his host, is appalled by this and rebukes him and tells him that he doesn't talk like a Christian. And Darnley, he snaps his fingers in Lord Trakai's face. What are we not to work a mare well when she is with foe? And this goes down like a lead balloon with Lord Trakai, with Mary's attendance and with Mary herself. And she seems to have been so offended by this that she breaks the holiday off and leaves early. She's quite right. Yeah, I think she is. Yeah.
说实话，我以前以为他是个坏人，但现在听了他说话的方式。他说话就是这个德行。我觉得他比我想象的还要糟糕。虽然还不如希姆莱那么坏，但也许正在向那个级别靠拢。是的，他能拿奖牌了。他站上领奖台了。不管怎样，玛丽可以理解地回到了爱丁堡的荷里路德宫，回到了她的宝贝儿子小詹姆斯身边。小詹姆斯被英国大使描述为“身材匀称，有望成为一位虔诚的王子”。当然，显然没看过他的舌头。玛丽对达恩利可能会搞出什么花样感到非常焦虑，以至于她把达恩利从荷里路德宫转移到了
I mean, to be honest, I thought he was a bad man, but now that I've heard him speak. That's exactly how he spoke. I think he's even worse than I had imagined. Not quite as bad as Himmler still, but maybe nudging up there. Yeah, he's in the medals. He's on the podium. Anyway, so Mary, understandably, she goes back to Edinburgh to Holyrood and to her baby, little James, who is described by the English ambassador as being well proportioned and like to prove a godly prince. I mean, hasn't looked at his tongue, obviously. And Mary is so anxious about what Darnley might get up to that she moves him from Holyrood to
斯特林（Stirling），在途中詹姆斯由500名火枪手护卫。当然，斯特林正是玛丽的母亲吉斯的玛丽（Mary of Guise）当年带她去寻求庇护的那座城堡。我认为玛丽担心的是，达恩利可能会劫持詹姆斯并自立为摄政王，这随后将使他基本上能够——甚至可能囚禁玛丽，当然也可以将她边缘化，并在詹姆斯成年之前以摄政王的身份实际统治苏格兰。因此，如果玛丽控制了詹姆斯，基本上就切断了达恩利的这种可能性。玛丽认识到，问题一直都是老问题，那就是达恩利并不
Stirling and en route James is guarded by 500 musketeers. And of course, Stirling is the very castle where Mary's mother, Mary of Gies, had taken her to keep her for safekeeping. What Mary is worried about, I think, is that Darnley might seize James and appoint himself as regent, and that would then enable him essentially, perhaps even to imprison Mary, certainly to kind of sideline her and effectively rule Scotland as regent until James comes of age. So if Mary has control of James, then essentially she's blocking that option off for Darnley. Mary recognizes that the issue is what it's always been, which is that Darnley is not
满足于他作为王夫的地位，他想成为国王。他想成为苏格兰国王，而玛丽曾经答应过他，后来又改变了主意。正因如此，达恩利一直在密谋。他不断想出各种阴谋诡计。所以他不仅在密谋让自己成为苏格兰国王。疯狂的是，他还想让自己成为英格兰国王。他想出了一个——简直是太疯狂的计划。他想攻占斯卡伯勒（Scarborough）。就像哈罗德·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）。对。
content with his status as a kind of a consort, that he wants to be king. He wants to be the King of Scotland, which Mary had promised him and then had kind of changed her mind. And because of this, Darnley is endlessly plotting. He's endlessly coming up with schemes. So he's not just plotting to make himself King of Scotland. Madly, he also wants to make himself King of England. He's come up with, I mean, just such a mad scheme. He wants to capture Scarborough. Like Harold Hardrada. Yeah.
所以斯卡伯勒是一个相当——我的意思是，它非常风景如画，非常有吸引力。它有一个很棒 板球节，但我认为公平地说，它并不是英格兰的伟大据点之一。它只是约克郡海岸的一个小渔村。他想拿下的另一个据点是锡利群岛（Scilly Isles），那是康沃尔郡西南角外的一群群岛。他的计划是攻占这些地方，然后从欧洲引入天主教军队。接着他将用这些来自斯卡伯勒和锡利群岛的军队对英格兰发动入侵。这完全是疯了。我们其实应该
So Scarborough is a rather, I mean, it's very picturesque, very attractive. It has a wonderful cricket festival, but it's not one of the great strongholds of England, I think it's fair to say. It's a kind of fishing village on the Yorkshire coast. And the other stronghold he wants to get is the Silly Isles, which are an archipelago off the southwest corner of Cornwall. And his plan is that he's going to capture these places and then he's going to import Catholic armies from Europe. And he will then launch an invasion of England with these armies from Scarborough and the Silly Isles. And it's completely mad. We should
提醒听众，达恩利是天主教徒。所以这也是其中一部分。因此，这个阴谋泡汤了，你知道的，它还没出生就夭折了。他为此感到备受羞辱，于是大发雷霆，宣布他要离开玛丽，他受够她了，他要去国外定居。人们可能会想，嗯，这倒是个不错的解决办法，不是吗？嗯，并不是，首先，这会对玛丽以及推而广之的苏格兰造成极大的羞辱。
actually remind listeners that Adarnley is Catholic. So this is part of the mix as well. So this plot falls through, you know, it's absolutely stillborn. He's humiliated by this and so he then has a massive strop and announces that he is going to leave Mary, he's had enough of her and he's going to go and settle abroad. And people might think, well, that's quite a good solution, isn't it? Well, it isn't firstly, because it would be very humiliating for Mary and by extension, Scotland.
但这也是新教贵族们的噩梦，因为他们最不希望看到的就是一个对苏格兰王位有继承权的天主教徒，在欧洲大陆与法国和西班牙等天主教势力勾结，给他们制造麻烦。因此他们对此怒不可遏。玛丽惊骇不已。她花了一整夜试图让他明白道理，说：“你知道的，这太疯狂了。请别这么做。”他拒绝了。于是她召集了枢密院，命令达恩利在枢密院前出庭，枢密院要求达恩利解释——你知道的，你在搞什么鬼？你在这里做什么？他根本给不出一个可信的回答，因为基本上他的回答是
But also it would be a nightmare for the Protestant Lords, because the last thing that they want is a Catholic with a claim to the throne of Scotland, making a message for them with the Catholic powers of France and Spain or whatever on the continent. And so they are irate about it. Mary is appalled. She spends a whole night trying to make him see sense, saying, you know, this is mad. Please don't do this. He refuses. And so she summons the Privy Council and she orders Darnley to appear before the Privy Council and the Privy Council asks Darnley to explain, you know, what are you up to? What are you doing here? He can't really give a credible answer because basically his answer
“哦，你知道的，我很生气，你知道的，你们没有好好对待我。对，我要去过一段间隔年（gap year）。”我的意思是，这基本上就是他的说辞。而枢密院被他的这番话震惊和惊骇得无以复加。他们正式写信给法国的凯瑟琳·德·美第奇（Catherine de Medici），说：“听着，这家伙是个疯子，别跟他有任何瓜葛。如果他真的去了法国，企图建立一个流亡王室或者制造麻烦什么的，千万别理他。”而我认为，他是个疯子的说法就是从这里开始产生的，因为伊丽莎白在你引用的那封信中提到他疯了。我认为这开始成为外交八卦的一部分。他是一个如此巨大的国际耻辱，以至于说他疯了，要比说“我们就是无法控制他”受到的羞辱更小一些。
is, oh, you know, I'm cross, you know, you're not treating me right. Yeah, I'm going off on a gap. Yeah. I mean, that's basically his pitch. And the privy council are so kind of stunned and appalled by what they've heard from him. They write officially to Catherine de Medici in France and say, look, this guy is a lunatic, have nothing to do with him. And if he does come to France and tries to set up a royal court in exile or to create mischief or whatever, just do not touch him. And this, I think, is where the notion that he is a lunatic starts to come because Elizabeth, in that letter that that you quoted refers to him as being mad. And I think that this is becoming part of the diplomatic chatter. He's such an international embarrassment that saying that he's mad is less of a humiliation
所以随着达恩利逐渐被边缘化，这是否意味着玛丽现在必须依靠许多她以前闹翻过的人？例如，如果她在与法国人交谈，她的外交政策专家就是这个名叫梅特兰的家伙，他曾是她的国务大臣，在里佐谋杀案后失宠。是的，他确实失宠了，但我认为他基本上一直是“玛丽战队”的。我想玛丽也知道这一点。
than saying, well, we just can't control him. So we're darnly moving towards the sort of margins. Does that mean that Mary now has to rely on a lot of people that she's previously fallen out with? So for example, if she's talking to the French, her foreign policy expert is this bloke Maitland, who was her secretary of state, who had been disgraced after the Ritzio murder. Yeah, he had, but I think he'd always basically been Team Mary. And I think Mary knows that.
正如你所说，我的意思是，她需要他的建议。于是他被免除了耻辱，实际上得到了赦免，并恢复了他国务大臣的职务。但有一个条件，那就是梅特兰必须与一个苏格兰贵族和解——玛丽现在对这个人的依赖超过了其他人，因为他证明了自己始终如一的忠诚，这个人就是博思韦尔伯爵（Earl of Bothwell）。博思韦尔是个趾高气扬、肌肉发达、留着一撮极其显眼的红胡子的人。我觉公平地说，他非常喜欢打架。但他十多年来一直是玛丽的坚强后盾，因为当吉斯的玛丽——
And as you say, I mean, she needs his advice. So he's brought out of his disgrace, he's effectively pardoned and he's restored to his post as secretary of state. But there is one condition and that is that Maitland is reconciled with the one Scottish Lord on whom Mary is now relying more than any other because he has proved himself consistently loyal and this is the Earl of Bothwell. And Bothwell is this swaggering, muscle bound, got a tremendous ginger mustache. Very fond of a punch up, I think it's fair to say. But he's been at Mary's back for a decade and more because he stood behind Mary of Geys,
她的母亲陷入困境时，他一直坚定地站在她身后。在里佐谋杀案发生后，博思韦尔挺身而出支持她的事业，并且博思韦尔曾帮助将莫顿和他的同谋赶进流亡。不过，博思韦尔这个非常强悍的男人，在那年秋天却遭遇了袭击，不是吗？我的意思是，这是有史以来最具有苏格兰特色的一幕，他遭到袭击，身受危及生命的重伤，而袭击他的人名叫——来吧，他叫什么名字？他叫“小乔克·埃利奥特”（Little Jock Elliott）。是的，他曾在20世纪80年代为邓弗姆林（Dunfermline）踢过球。是的，所以这个小乔克·埃利奥特是一个臭名昭著的强盗（reaver）。当然他是。
her mother, when she'd been in trouble. Bothwell had rallied to her cause in the wake of Ritio's murder and Bothwell had helped to drive Morton and his fellow conspirators into exile. Bothwell, though a very formidable man, is on the receiving end, isn't he, that autumn? I mean the most Scottish thing that's ever happened, he's been attacked, left with life threatening injuries by a man who's called Come on, what's, what's he called? He's called little jock Elliott. Yeah, so he played for Dumferlin in the 1980s. Yeah, so he is little Jock Elliott is a notorious reaver. Of course he is.
强盗是那些盘踞在英格兰和苏格兰边境地区的土匪，尤其是这个被称为“争议之地”（debatable lands）的地区，这是一段边境地带。而作为博思韦尔祖传宅邸的Hermitage城堡，绝对就位于争议之地的中心。我喜欢这样一个事实：在经历了700集节目之后，人们一直在问：“你们什么时候才讲苏格兰历史？讲点苏格兰历史吧。”我们本来可以讲苏格兰启蒙运动。我们本可以挑选任何元素，但相反，我们却选择了诸如在争议之地互撞脑袋、名叫“小乔克”的人，因为
The Reavers are the bandits who infest the border regions between England and Scotland, and particularly this region called the debatable lands, which is a stretch of the border. And the Hermitage, which is Bothwell's ancestral pile is absolutely at the centre of the debatable lands. I love the fact that after 700 episodes and people have been like, when are you going to do Scottish history? Do some Scottish history. We could have done the Scottish enlightenment. We could have chosen any element, but instead we chose like people headbutting each other in debatable lands called Little Jock, because
我们绝对想要倾向于他们对苏格兰是什么的理解。我的意思是，为了让苏格兰听众放心，争议之地是不仅在苏格兰、而且在整个英国最无法无天、匪患猖獗的角落。所以我们正在强调这一点。这显然就是为什么博思韦尔如此好斗的原因，因为你必须好暴戾才能在这样的地貌中立足。所以是的，他遇袭了，险些丧命，浑身都是各种伤口。这个消息被带给了玛丽，她当时在杰德堡（Jedburgh），距离那儿向东大约25英里。她正在巡回审判（on assizes）。所以她到处听取她的臣民的抱怨——基本上是在展示她履行王室职责。
we absolutely wanted to lean into their sense of what Scotland is. I mean, just to reassure Scottish listeners, the debatable lands are the most lawless and bandit-ridden corner, not just in Scotland, but in all of Britain. So we are emphasizing that. And this clearly is why Bothwell is so given to violence is that you have to be violent to hold your own in this kind of landscape. So yeah, so he's attacked and left for dead, covered with all kinds of wounds. The news is brought to Mary, who at the time is in Jedborough, which is about 25 miles away to the east. And she's on a sizes. So she's going around hearing complaints from
后来流传的八卦是，她一听到博思韦尔遇袭的消息，就离开杰德堡，独自一人策马奔向Hermitage城堡。这不是真的。她等了一个星期，因为她还有巡回审判要听取，她也没有独自骑马去。所以，莫里（Moray），她的同母异父兄弟，和她一起去了，梅特兰也在场，还有一大批随从。即便如此，我的意思是，这也是一个惊人的骑术壮举，
her subjects, basically kind of showing herself doing her royal duties. The gossip will be that is reported later is that the moment she hears the news that Bothwell has been attacked, she leaves Jedborough and gallops off alone to the Hermitage. This is not true. She waits for a week because she still has the assizes to hear and nor does she ride there alone. So, Morrie, her half-brother, he goes with her, Maitland is there, a large retinue. But even so, I mean, it is a startling feat of horsemanship
因为来回有25英里，地形非常崎岖。我的意思是，我去过那里并亲眼见过，我非常尊敬玛丽能走那么远。她在博思韦尔的床边呆了两个小时，情况很明显，博思韦尔不会死，他正在康复的路上。然后他们骑马返回。所以这是一个充实而活跃的一天。而事实证明，这对玛丽来说有点吃力了。她回到杰德堡后，生了一场非常非常危险的大病。所以无论是由于过度劳累——如果她曾怀孕的话，她曾向达恩利提及此事，但到这个时候她可能已经流产了，所以可能是流产后的后遗症，我不确定。但可以肯定的是，人们开始为她的生命担忧。
because it's 25 miles there, I have a really very rough terrain. I mean, I've been there and seen it and I respect Mary very highly for having traveled that far. She spends two hours by Bothwell's bedside and it becomes clear that Bothwell isn't going to die, that he's on the road to recovery. And then they ride back. So that is a full and active day. And it turns out to be too much for Mary. She gets back to Jed Barone, she falls very, very dangerously ill. So whether it's over exertion, if she had been pregnant, she mentioned this to Darnley, I think by this point she's lost the baby, so it may be the after effects of a miscarriage, I'm not sure. But certainly her life is feared for.
有一次，她躺在床上半个小时，“我引述：双眼紧闭，嘴唇紧闭，手脚僵硬冰冷”。莫里伯爵，她的同母异父兄弟——我认为他满腔怨恨，恨她贵为女王而他不是国王，你知道的，这只是因为他私生子身份的意外——开始把手伸向她所有的银质餐具和戒指。这就像亨利五世在父亲死前抢走王冠一样。而玛丽没有死，因为她有一个非常高明的法国医生，他能够把她从死亡边缘拉回来。而在她似乎快要死去的两周后，她准备继续她的行程。这次濒死体验的影响对玛丽来说非常深远，我认为。我认她开始真正思考：我究竟要留下一个什么样的王国？
At one point she lies in bed for half an hour and I quote, eyes closed, mouth fast and feet and arms stiff and cold. The Earl of Moray, her half brother, who I think is consumed with resentment that she is the queen and he's not the king, you know, an accident of his illegitimacy. He starts laying hands on all her silver plate and rings. So it's like Henry V making off with the crown before his father is dead. And Mary doesn't die because she has a very skillful French doctor and he is able to kind of bring her back from the brink of death. And two weeks on from when it seemed like she was going to die, she's ready to continue on her way. And the impact of this near-death experience is very profound, I think for Mary. I think that she really starts to think, you know, what kind of kingdom am I going to leave
这在苏格兰贵族中引发了巨大的焦虑高峰。他们不想要政权更迭。他们不希望达恩利逍遥法外。他们担心这会导致无政府状态。因此，他们坚定地致力于让玛丽继续坐在王位上，并确保达恩利不会给她带来太多麻烦。那么问题来了，我们究竟该如何处理达恩利？我的意思是，我们怎么能确保玛丽不会被他没完没了的麻烦所纠缠？他们到底能做些什么？我们能做什么？正是国务大臣梅特兰——就是那个当初以非常微妙含蓄的言辞首次建议谋杀里佐的人——现在再次开始试探这种可能性，也许
behind? It generates a massive anxiety spike among the Scottish nobility. They don't want a change of regime. They don't want Darnley on the loose. They are worried that it will result in anarchy. And so they are very committed to keeping Mary on the throne and ensuring that Darnley doesn't cause her too much trouble. And the question then is, well, how are we going to deal with Darnley? I mean, how are we going to make sure that Mary isn't kind of embroiled in endless trouble from him? What on earth could they possibly do? What could we do? And it is Maitland, the Secretary of State, who was the guy who had first suggested the murder of Ritio in very kind of subtle insinuating terms, who again now starts to broach the possibility, maybe,
可以进行另一次谋杀。所以他甚至写信将此诉诸文字。因此，在玛丽经历这场生死劫难后不久，他写信给苏格兰驻巴黎大使：想到他竟然是她的丈夫，这让她心碎，而至于如何摆脱他，她看不到出路。但很明显，你知道的，他是在暗示他或许可以。他正与玛丽从杰德堡同行，他们前往一个叫做克雷格米勒城堡（CraigMiller Castle）的地方，并于11月20日抵达那里，该城堡位于爱丁堡南部，他是天主教徒，这意味着他绝对可靠。我的意思是，他是完完全全的“玛丽战队”。
of another murder. So he even goes so far as to kind of put this into writing. So he writes to the Scottish ambassador in Paris shortly after Mary has had this brush with death. It is a heartbreak for her to think that he should be her husband and how to be free of him she sees no way out. But obviously, you know, he is suggesting that he might. He is traveling with Mary from Jeddah and they go to a place called Craig Miller Castle and they arrive there on the 20th of November, it's just south of Edinburgh, and it's layered as Catholic, which means that he is absolutely reliable. I mean, he's completely Team Mary.
玛丽到达那里后，又病倒了。于是她随从中的所有贵族——其中包括梅特兰、莫里，以及此时已经从病榻上爬起来的博思韦尔（因为他虽然浑身是伤，但粗鲁强悍）——都在她卧病在床期间，有时间讨论可以拿达恩利怎么办。当玛丽康复后，他们去见她，除了莫里之外——莫里此时对谈话转向的方向感到担忧，并不真的想参与其中。但梅特兰、博思韦尔和其他小伙子们一起去找玛丽，说：“听着，你必须和达恩利离婚。”玛丽认为她不应该和达恩利离婚，因为那只会让他逍遥法外，但其他所有人都认为，干吧。玛丽听了他们的意见，原则上表示同意，但她的焦虑显然是这不会对詹姆斯造成损害。她说：“我同意，前提是对我的儿子没有损害。”是的。
And Mary gets there and she then falls ill again. And so all the lords in her retinue, which include Maitland, Moray, and by this time, Bothwell, because he's risen up from his sick bed, he's covered in scars, but he's kind of rough and tough. They all have time while she's lying in her sick bed to discuss what might be done with Darnley. And when Mary recovers, they go to see her, all except for Moray, who by this point is worried at the way in which the conversation is turning and doesn't really want to be a part of it. But Maitland and Bothwell and all the other lads, they go to Mary and they say, look, you have got to divorce Darnley. Mare does not think that she should divorce Darnley because that would just leave him
然后她问：“莫里呢？他同意吗？因为我注意到他不在。”梅特兰回答说：“我确信他也会对那件事睁一只眼闭一只眼，他会看着我们所做的一切，
on the loose, but all the others think, yeah, let's go for it. Mary listens to them and she kind of agrees in principle, but her anxiety obviously is that it wouldn't be damaging to James. She says, I will have it provided it is not prejudicial to my son. Yeah. And then she asks, well, is Moray, does he agree to this? Because I noticed he's not here and Maitland answers, I am assured he will look through his fingers there too, and will behold our doings
对此什么也不说。”换句话说，他只是打算让我们继续干下去。是的。很明显，如果只是一场离婚，就不会是什么大不了的事。但这暗示着这可能不仅仅是一场离婚。这可能是一个稍微更加永久的分离，我们可以这么说。这是梅特兰随后向玛丽透露的暗示，玛丽对此变得非常激动，
saying nothing to the same. In other words, he's just going to let us kind of get on with it. Yeah. And obviously if it was just a divorce, it wouldn't be such a big deal. But that implies that this may be more than a divorce. That it may be a slightly more permanent separation, shall we say. That is a hint that Maitland then drops to Mary, which Mary becomes very agitated and
她逼问梅特兰：“你知道的，你到底是什么意思？”她接着说道：“我希望你们不要做出任何可能玷污我的荣誉或良心的事。因此我恳求你们，宁可让事情保持原样，也就是说，不要谋杀他。”而现在，让我们把离婚的问题先搁在一边。但时间在一分一秒地流逝，不是吗？因为他们要为儿子詹姆斯洗礼，我猜如果达恩利出现在洗礼上并以詹姆斯父亲的身份自居，那可能会稍微改变局面，但非常愚蠢的是，洗礼在
she presses Maitland, well, you know, what exactly do you mean? And she goes on to say, I will that ye do nothing where to any spot may be laid to my honor or conscience. And therefore I pray you rather let the matter be in the state as it is, i.e. don't murder him. And for now, let's leave the whole question of divorce to one side. But the clock is ticking a little bit isn't it because they're going to christen James their son and I suppose if Darnley had turned up to that and sort of asserted himself as James's father that might have slightly changed the game but very foolishly it happens at
斯特林举行，对吧？12月17日。是的。而达恩利大发脾气，拒绝出席，因为他因为自己不是国王而生气。错过自己亲生儿子的洗礼，行为真是太糟糕了，因为你知道的，你戴不上王冠。对。是的。
sterling doesn't it? 17th of December. Yeah. And Darnley has a massive tantrum and refuses to come because he's crossed that he's not King. Such poor behavior to miss the christen of your own son, because you know, you can't wear a crown. Yeah. Yeah.
所以他不在场。不过现场有一个人玛丽可以求助来填补他的位置。这个人就是伤痕累累、留着八字胡的博思韦尔伯爵。他得在这样的场合看起来精明干练。因此玛丽特意为他提供了一套非常精美、华丽的蓝色衣服。于是博思韦尔大摇大摆地走来走去，显得威风凛凛。当然，这受到了极大的关注。
So he's not there. There is a man on hand who Mary can turn to, to take down his place. And this is the much scarred and mustachioed Earl of Bothwell. He's got to look smart for the occasion. And so Mary makes sure to provide him with a very fine outfit of kind of gorgeous blue clothes. And so Bothwell is strutting around looking tremendous. And of course, this is much noted.
对。是的。人们注意到达恩利不在场，但博思韦尔穿这身西装看起来真棒。但就连博思韦尔也拒绝出席洗礼仪式。博思韦尔的老对手莫里——玛丽同父异母的兄弟——也没有出席，因为他们是新教徒，而洗礼仪式是天主教的。对。所以这看起来好像整件事成了一场灾难。
Right. Yeah. People observe that Darnley isn't there, but Bothwell's looking great in his suit. But even Bothwell refuses to attend the christening. And so does Moray, Bothwell's old rival, Mary's half-sister, because they're Protestants and the ceremony, the baptism is a Catholic one. Right. So it might look as though the whole thing has been a disaster.
达恩利不在场，博思韦尔引起了闲话，博思韦尔和莫里都没有出席洗礼，但实际上，幕后却是一场大胜，因为在贵族们密谋如何处置达恩利的同时，玛丽——我说过她的心思真的高度集中，她真的在想：我究竟想要未来怎样？——于是她写信给英格兰的伊丽莎白，以女王对女王的身份，没有通过梅特兰，也没有通过塞西尔。她对伊丽莎白说：“听着，我差点死去，我一直在担心我的
Darnley's not there. Bothwell is creating gossip, Bothwell and Moray aren't attending the baptism, but actually it's been a triumph behind the scenes because what has been happening while the Lords have been plotting what to do about Darnley is that Mary, I said that her mind has really been concentrated, she's really thinking, well, what do I want from the future? And so she has written to Elizabeth in England, queen to queen, not going through Maitland, not going through Cecil. And she says to Elizabeth, look, I've very nearly died and I've been worrying about my
儿子。所以我请求的是，如果我死了，你愿意成为詹姆スの保护人吗？实际上这意味着成为詹姆スの养母。”伊丽莎白对此深感触动并欣然接受，作为象征，她同意成为詹姆スの教母，尽管洗礼仪式是天主教的。她送给玛丽一尊镶满珠宝的纯金精美洗礼盆。两位女王之间的缓和（detente）——她们之间的关系此前一直相当紧张——现在已经足够融洽，以至于她们可以继续讨论政策，而无需诉诸各自的大臣，并开始私下谈判那个一直是玛丽终极梦想的事情，即被伊丽莎白承认
son. So what I request is that if I die, would you become James's protector, which in effect means becoming James's foster mother. And Elizabeth is very touched by this and she accepts and as a token of this, she agrees to be James's godmother, even though the baptism ceremony is a Catholic one. And she sends Mary this magnificent bejeweled font of solid gold. And the detente between the two queens, you know, relations between them had been quite tense. It's now sufficient that they can continue to discuss policy without recourse to their respective ministers and begin privately negotiating over what had always been Mary's ultimate dream, namely to be acknowledged by Elizabeth
为英格兰王位的法定继承人。哇，这对玛丽来说看起来不错。这对玛丽来说确实不错，而且正是她的病情促成了这种外交突破，你知道的，这种私人对话。而且我认为作为其中的一部分，玛丽也在想：既然我与伊丽莎白和解了，为什么我不让其他人也和解呢？为什么我不能让所有人实现和解呢？所以在平安夜，她正式赦免了里佐阴谋的策划者。也就是莫顿和那一帮人。
as heir apparent to the throne of England. Wow, that's looking good for Mary. It is looking good for Mary and it was her illness that precipitated this kind of diplomatic breakthrough, you know, that this private conversation. And I think also as part of this, Mary is thinking, I'm reconciled with Elizabeth, why don't I get everybody else to be reconciled with Elizabeth, why don't I get everybody else to be reconciled? So on Christmas Eve, she formally pardons the Ritzio plotters. So that's Morton and all that gang.
1月6日，她允许梅特兰迎娶“时髦玛丽”（Posh Mary，四个玛丽之一），梅特兰尽管与她有20岁的年龄差距，却一直深深地爱着她。1月9日，莫顿从贝里克（Berwick）进入苏格兰。他回家了。1月14日，莫顿和梅特兰在一个叫做惠廷汉姆城堡（Whittingham Castle）的地方会面，这距离爱丁堡也是骑马几英里的路程，首都周围点缀着所有这些城堡。出席他们会面的是他们里佐阴谋的老对手——那个在里佐被谋杀时玛丽曾向其求助的人，即博思韦尔伯爵。
On the 6th of January, she allows Maitland to marry Posh Mary, the one of the four Marys who Maitland had been desperately in love with despite the 20 year age gap. And on the 9th of January, Morton crosses from Berwick into Scotland. He is home. And on the 14th of January, Morton and Maitland meet at a place called Whittingham Castle, which is again a few miles ride from Edinburgh, all these castles dotted around the capital. And present for their meeting is their old adversary from the Ritio plot, the man who Mary had turned to when Ritio got murdered, the Earl of Bothwell.
太惊人了。两拨不同的人聚在一起讨论事情。我的意思是，这三个人到底在讨论什么？与此同时，达恩利发生了什么事？他拒绝出席自己亲儿子的洗礼。他是去打猎了，还是去密谋更阴险的事情了？嗯，他又回到了他的老本行——密谋。他的阴谋正是玛丽一直担心他会做的事，那就是绑架詹姆斯并囚禁她。因此她对此感到悲叹并写信给
So amazing. Two different groups of people meeting up to discuss things. I mean, what could they be discussing, these three men? While all that's happening, what's happened to Darnley? He refused to come to the baptism of his own son. Has he just been off hunting or has he been plotting something more sinister? Well, he's returned to his plotting. His plot is exactly what Mary's been worried he might do, which is to abduct James and to imprison her. And so she laments this and writes to
梅特兰：“至于国王，我们的丈夫，我们总是发觉他忙于打听我们的行踪。”换句话说，他正试图摸清她的行踪，以便绑架她。尽管达恩利身体一直不太好，事实上他确实染上了严重的梅毒，显然如此。但当然。他还能得什么病？从玛丽的角度来看，不祥的是，他的病房在格拉斯哥（Glasgow），那是他父亲伦诺克斯伯爵（Earl of Lennox）的大本营。这令人担忧。我的意思是，玛丽既不想应付达恩利，也不想招惹伦诺克斯。所以她想：我得把他弄回来。我不能允许他跟父亲待在那儿。所以我认为她非常勇敢地骑马去了格拉斯哥，她在病榻上照顾他，并敦促他回来
Maitland, for the king, our husband, always we perceive him occupied and busy enough to have inquisition of our doings. So in other words, he's trying to map out what her movements are so that he can abduct her. And this is despite the fact that Darnley hasn't been very well and actually he gets really seriously ill with syphilis, obviously. But of course. What else would he have? And ominously from Mary's point of view, his sick room is in Glasgow, which is the great power base of his father, the Earl of Lennox. And this is alarming. I mean, Mary doesn't want trouble from Lennox as well as from Darnley. And so she thinks, I've got to get him back. I can't allow him to be there with his father. So I think very bravely, she rides to Glasgow, she tends to him in his sick bed and she urges him to come
梅特兰，为了国王，也就是我们的丈夫，我们始终觉得他一直在关注和探查我们的行踪。也就是说，他正试图摸清她的行动路线以便绑架她。尽管达利当时的身体状况并不好，甚至显然染上了梅毒而病得很重，但事实确实如此。当然了。他还能得别的什么病呢？从玛丽的角度来看，不祥的是，他的病房设在格拉斯哥，那是他父亲伦诺克斯伯爵的大本营。这让人感到警惕。我的意思是，玛丽既不想招惹达利，也不想招惹伦诺克斯。因此她认为，我必须把他弄回来。我不能允许他和父亲待在那里。所以我觉得她非常勇敢，她骑马去了格拉斯哥，在病榻前照顾他，并极力劝说他回来
back with her and specifically she says, come back with me to Craig Miller Castle. You'll be much better there. You'll be near Edinburgh. We can look after you properly. Darnley initially refuses. He feels safe and secure in Glasgow. But finally he agrees. Yes. Why does he agree to do this? So John Guy's theory is, and I quote, to win over Darnley, Mary had to prove her affection for him in the only way his carnal and degenerate nature understood. This meant offering to have sex with him again as soon as he was cured. He's very into the notion that Mary is endlessly promising Darnley sex as a way of kind of trying to reign him in. I think there is another possible reason why Darnley agrees to come back with Mary and basically try and be reconciled with her, which is of course that Morton is now back on the scene.
同她回去，而且他明确说：“跟我回克雷格米勒城堡吧。你在那里会好得多。你离爱丁堡很近。我们可以好好照顾你。”达利起初拒绝了。他在格拉斯哥感到安全和安心。但最后他同意了。是的。他为什么同意这样做？因此，约翰·盖伊的理论是，我引述一下：“为了赢得达利的好感，玛丽必须以他那好色且堕落的天性唯一能理解的方式来证明她对他的爱。”这意味着一旦他病愈，就主动提出再次与他发生性关系。他非常相信玛丽不断向达利承诺性爱，以此作为试图控制他的一种方式。我认为达利同意跟玛丽回去并基本上试图与她和解，还有另一个可能的原因，当然就是莫顿现在又重新回到了公众视野中。
Morton was the co-conspirator in the Rizzio plot who Darnley spectacularly double-crossed. Morton is not the kind of guy who takes being double-crossed lying down. He is a very, very menacing and dangerous opponent. I think that Darnley probably is thinking, you know, Mary, now I need her, if I'm going to be kept safe from Morton. He says, I'm not going to go to Craigmillar Castle because it's layered, as we mentioned, is two team Mary, it's two kind of pro-Stewart. So he's probably worried that Mary might lock him up in Craigmillar Castle, you know, it's a place full of dungeons. He also says, I'm not going to go to Holyrood because he's covered in weeping pustules and he's far too vain.
莫顿是里佐阴谋案的同谋，而达利曾对莫顿进行了惊人的双重背叛。莫顿可不是那种遭到背叛后会逆来顺受的家伙。他是一个非常、非常具有威胁性和危险性的对手。我想达利大概在想，你知道的，玛丽，我现在需要她，如果我要免受莫顿的伤害的话。他说：“我不想去克雷格米勒城堡，因为那里如我们所提到的，里面充满了玛丽的人，对斯图亚特王朝过于忠诚。”所以他可能担心玛丽会把他关在克雷格米勒城堡里，你知道的，那是个充满地牢的地方。他还说：“我不想去荷里路德宫，”因为他浑身长满流脓的脓疱，而且他太爱虚荣了。
He doesn't want to be seen, you know, covered in spots. He's not a very appetizing prospect for her to sleep with. I mean, so if she has made that offer, that's a big offer from her. Yes, absolutely. So Dunlea probably is going back with Mary and feeling slightly fonder towards her than he had previously done. And Mary is obviously trying to be as nice to him as she possibly can because she's essentially trying to wrangle him.
他不想被别人看到，你知道的，浑身长满斑点。对她而言，他并不是一个很有吸引力的同床共枕对象。我的意思是，如果她真的提出了那个条件，那对她来说可是一个巨大的让步。是的，绝对如此。所以达利大概是在和玛丽一起回去的路上，对她的好感比以前稍微增加了一些。而玛丽显然在尽其所能对她表现得好，因为她本质上是在试图安抚他。
And so she agrees to Darnley's proposal, which is that rather than stay in Holyrood or in Craigmiller, he will stay in relative isolation on the edge of Edinburgh and he suggests a house right next to the city wall. The house is barely furnished and it stands beside the Kirker Field, a ruined medieval church. It's simultaneously isolated so no one can see his spots, but it's near enough to Holyrood that Mary can come out and visit him, So it seems perfect. So on the 1st of February, Mary arrives in Edinburgh. He's got Darnley in a horse litter. Darnley is installed in the house at Kirkerfield and there he is to wait while his treatment for syphilis is completed and his weeping pustules
于是她同意了达利的提议，即与其住在荷里路德宫或克雷格米勒，他不如住在爱丁堡边缘一个相对隐蔽的地方，他提议了一栋紧挨着城墙的房子。这栋房子几乎没有什么家具，它矗立在一座名为“教会旷野”（Kirker Field）的废弃中世纪教堂旁。这里既与世隔绝，没人能看到他的斑点，但又离荷里路德宫足够近，玛丽可以出来探望他，所以这看起来堪称完美。因此，在2月1日，玛丽抵达了爱丁堡。达利坐在马轿里，被安置在教会旷野的房子里，他将在那里等待，直到他的梅毒治疗完成以及他那流脓的脓疱
dry up. The course goes very well. A week and a half pass, Darnley is almost ready to come out of the house at the Kirker Field. And then in the early hours of the 10th of February, around two o'clock in the morning, Mary and the most of Edinburgh are awakened by a massive flash of light and then an enormous explosion. And we're told that the sound of the explosion was equivalent to the firing of 30 cannons. And the next day, Mary writes to her ambassador in France with news of what had happened. The matter is horrible, she wrote. And so strange as we believe the like was never heard of in any country. Darnley, her husband, the man with more enemies probably than any man has ever had in Scotland, is dead. By whom it has been done, Mary writes to the ambassador in France, or in what matter, it
结痂。治疗进展得非常顺利。一个半星期过去了，达利几乎准备好离开教会旷野的房子了。然后，在2月10日清晨，大约凌晨两点左右，玛丽和爱丁堡的大多数居民被一道巨大的闪光和随之而来的巨大爆炸声惊醒。我们听说爆炸的声音相当于30门大炮齐鸣。第二天，玛丽向她驻法国的大使写信，告知了所发生的事情。“事情非常可怕，”她写道，“而且如此离奇，我们相信在任何国家都从未听说过类似的事情。”达利，她的丈夫，这个在苏格兰树敌可能比任何人都要多的男人，已经死了。玛丽在写给法国大使的信中说道，究竟是谁干的，或者以何种方式干的，
appears not as yet. Crikey. Well, on that bombshell, Tom, I'm so excited. I think we should take a break. And when we return after the break, we will investigate, we will don a true crime podcasting kilts. And we will investigate what happened in the 24 hours leading up to Lord Darnley's murder. Tom, I think we should name the key conspirators.
目前尚不得而知。天哪。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，汤姆，我太激动了。我想我们应该休息一下。当我们休息回来后，我们将展开调查，我们将戴上苏格兰风格的真实罪案播客苏格兰短裙。我们将调查发生在大审判、不，是达利勋爵遇刺前24小时内的事情。汤姆，我认为我们应该点出关键的同谋者。
We should unmask the plotters. And we will answer the crucial question. Who did it and was it Mary Queen of Scots? So we'll see you after the break. This episode is brought to you by Surfshark. Now had Mary Queen of Scots been just a little bit more careful with her correspondence, then she might well have avoided becoming a cautionary tale of treason. So she slipped her ciphered letters
我们应该揭露阴谋策划者的面目。并且我们将回答那个至关重要的问题。是谁干的？这事会是苏格兰女王玛丽干的吗？所以我们休息后见。本集节目由 Surfshark 赞助播出。如果在信件往来上能再谨慎哪怕一点点的话，苏格兰女王玛丽或许就能避免成为叛国行为的反面教材了。所以她将加密信件
into beer barrels. Methods today have changed, but the risk of interception of course always remains. Your information is more vulnerable than ever and perhaps especially when it's online. Trackers and advertisers and apps collecting your data all the time. And if you're using public Wi-Fi, then your activity can be monitored by anyone who is sharing the network that you are on. And this is where Surfshark comes in. It's a VPN that encrypts your internet connection, thereby keeps your personal data secure. So you can also change your digital location, giving you access to your favorite sites and
塞进啤酒桶里。如今的方法已经改变了，但信息被拦截的风险当然依然存在。你的信息比以往任何时候都更加脆弱，特别是当它处于在线状态时。追踪者、广告商以及不断收集你数据的应用程序无处不在。如果你在使用公共 Wi-Fi，那么你的活动可能会被与你连接同一网络の任何其他人监控。这就是 Surfshark 派上用场的地方。它是一个加密你互联网连接的虚拟专用网络（VPN），从而确保你的个人数据的安全。所以你还可以更改你的数字位置，无论你在哪里，都能访问你最喜欢的网站和
streaming services wherever you are. So protect your data, browse securely from anywhere, no cipher, no courier, certainly no beer barrel required. Go to surfshark.com slash TRIH or you can use the code TRIH at the checkout to get four extra months of Surfshark VPN plus a 30 day money back guarantee. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, exciting true crime podcasting with a Scottish twist. So Tom, let's kick off in a place very close to your heart, which is Berwick on the Anglo-Scottish border. There's a bloke there called Sir William Drury and he is England's eyes and
流媒体服务。所以，请保护你的数据，随时随地安全浏览，无需密码，无需信使，当然也无需啤酒桶。前往 surfshark.com/TRIH，或者你可以在结账时使用代码 TRIH，即可获得四个月的额外 Surfshark VPN 以及 30 天退款保证。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History），这是一档带有苏格兰风情的精彩真实犯罪播客。那么，汤姆，让我们从一个对你来说非常熟悉的地方开始吧，那就是位于英苏边境的伯威克。那里有个叫威廉·德鲁里爵士（Sir William Drury）的家伙，他可以说是英国的耳目。
ears. He's the marshal of the town. He's basically an intelligence officer and he thinks he knows what's been going on, doesn't he? Because he sends a report within a day of Darnley's murder to Elizabeth the First Chief Minister William Cecil. So take us into that bit of the story. Yeah, so he has agents everywhere in Edinburgh and this initial report establishes the kind of parameters of the mystery, but he will continue to send increasingly detailed, increasingly forensic accounts of what he thinks happened. And I think
他是该镇的治安官。他基本上是一名情报官员，他认为自己知道发生了什么，对不对？因为他在达利遇害后的一天之内就向英国第一大臣威廉·塞西尔（William Cecil）发送了一份报告。所以，请带我们了解故事的这一部分吧。是的，因此他在爱丁堡到处都有特工，这份最初的报告确立了这起谜团的各种参数，但他将继续发送越来越详细、越来越具法医学分析的报告，阐述他认为发生了什么。我认为
that these reports combined with, we get confessions from participants in the conspiracy, testimonials from witnesses, and you put them all together. And I think that it does enable a fairly accurate account of the events that culminated in the death of Darnley to be drawn up. So when you look at these, what do they tell us? So let's look at Mary and Darnley first. Just to recap, Darnley had arrived at the place of his murder on the 1st of February 1567. And this is Kirkfield, which is a complex of houses built beside an old ruined church
这些报告结合了我们从阴谋参与者那里获得的供词、目击者的证词，当你把它们全部放在一起时。我认为这确实能够拼凑出一份相当准确的事件记述，正是这些事件最终导致了达利的死亡。那么，当你查看这些资料时，它们告诉了我们什么？所以让我们首先来看看玛丽和达利。简单回顾一下，达利于1567年2月1日抵达了他遇害的地方。这就是基克菲尔德（Kirkfield），这是一组建在爱丁堡南部边缘一座废弃老教堂旁的建筑群，
on the southern fringes of Edinburgh and the wall that had been built in the wake of the Battle of Flodden to keep the English out runs right past it. It's a very well chosen location for an invalid to recuperate. It's on a hill so it's above the kind of smoke and filth of Edinburgh. It's surrounded by gardens so there's fresh air there, very much more salubrious than Holyrood. And as we said, by the 9th of February, Darnley has been convalescing there for a week and a half and he's pretty much ready to go. The evening before Darnley is due to come back to Holyrood, Mary arrives in the evening with a whole train of lords
在弗洛顿战役之后为了把英国人挡在外面而修建的城墙就从它旁边穿过。对于一个养病的病人来说，这是一个精心选择的地理位置。它位于一座小山上，因此高于爱丁堡的烟雾和污秽。它周围环绕着花园，所以那里有新鲜空气，比荷里路德宫要健康得多。正如我们所说，到了2月9日，达利已经在那里休养了一个半星期，他基本上已经准备好离开了。就在达利返回荷里路德宫的前一天晚上，玛丽在傍晚时分带着一大群贵族和
and ladies, Bothwell very prominent among them, and they're celebrating this. They're celebrating the fact that Darnley will be coming back to join Mary the following day. And Mary is in an excellent mood. She feels that she's got Darnley back under her influence. He seems much more amenable than he had been. And that evening, Darnley is off his face on whiskey. He's developed a real taste for it. He starts groping her very publicly in front of everyone.
贵妇抵达了，博斯韦尔（Bothwell）也在其中格外显眼，他们在庆祝此事。他们在庆祝达利第二天将返回并与玛丽团聚。玛丽的心情非常好。她觉得她已经把达利重新拉回了自己的影响范围。他看起来比以前好说话多了。那天晚上，达利喝威士忌喝得酩酊大醉。他对威士忌产生了浓厚的兴趣。他当着所有人的面开始非常公开地对她动手动脚。
And rather than giving him a slap or telling him to leave her alone, she gives him a ring as a token of her affection. So things seem to be looking up for the happy couple. But I think the real reason that she's happy has nothing to do with Darnley and everything to do with these ongoing private negotiations with Elizabeth in England. It really looks now as though Mary's great dream of being publicly acknowledged as Elizabeth's heir might be on the verge of fulfillment. I mean, very hard to know with Elizabeth because she's always kind of playing hard to get, but Mary, I think, genuinely believes that her great dream might be close to fulfillment. So, Darnley wants Mary to stay with him the night, but Mary doesn't because
而她非但没有给他一巴掌或叫他离自己远点，反而送了他一枚戒指作为她爱意的象征。所以这对幸福的夫妇看起来一切都在向好的方向发展。但我认为她真正高兴的原因与达利毫无关系，而完全与她和英国伊丽莎白女王正在进行的这些私人谈判有关。现在看起来，玛丽公开被承认拟为伊丽莎白继承人的伟大梦想似乎即将实现。我的意思是，面对伊丽莎白很难猜透心思，因为她总是摆出一副难以接近的样子，但玛丽，我认为，真心相信她的伟大梦想可能已经接近实现了。所以，达利想让玛丽留下来陪他过夜，但玛丽没有留下，因为
one of her favorite servants has got married that afternoon and is holding a great celebration, a kind of wedding mask, and Mary has promised to go. Mary always keeps her promises to her servants and of course, also, she likes to dance. She doesn't want to miss out on that. So she leaves Darnley. She arrives back at Holyrood about 11 o'clock, she attends her servant's mask, but she doesn't stay too long. She's in bed by half past midnight and then at two o'clock, so an hour and a half later, she is woken by the destruction of Darnley's house at Kirk of Fields. And having heard the explosion, she summons Bothwell, who of course is the sheriff of Edinburgh, so it's his responsibility to investigate and Bothwell goes off.
她最喜欢的仆人之一那天下午结婚了，并且正在举行盛大的庆祝活动，一种类似婚礼假面舞会的活动，玛丽答应了要去。玛丽总是信守对仆人们的承诺，当然，她也很喜欢跳舞。她可不想错过这个机会。所以她离开了达利。她在大约11点回到荷里路德宫，参加了她仆人的假面舞会，但她并没有待太久。她在午夜十二点半前就上床睡觉了，然后在两点钟，也就是一个半小时后，她被达利在教会旷野的房子被炸毁的声音惊醒。听到爆炸声后，她召来了博斯韦尔，他当然是爱丁堡的郡长，所以调查是他的职责，博斯韦尔便出发了。
And when he comes back and he says that the house has been blown up and that Darnley has been found dead, witnesses are pretty much agreed that she is appalled by the news. And in a way that one might think is perhaps typical of Mary, she's appalled less for Darnley than by the thought that it might have been targeted at her. She says, this crime was dressed as well for us as for the king, for we lay the most part of all the last week in that same lodging and was there accompanied with the most part of the lords that are in this town that same night. So it's all about her basically.
当他回来并说房子被炸毁了，达利被发现已经死亡时，目击者们基本一致认为她对这个消息感到震惊。以一种人们可能会认为或许符合玛丽特点的方式，她感到的震惊与其说是为了达利，不如说是担心这可能是冲着她来的。她说：“这桩罪行不仅是针对国王，也是针对我们，因为在上周的大部分时间里，我们都住在那个同一处住所里，而且那天晚上，城里的大部分领主也都陪在那里。”所以这基本全是在说她自己。
But also, and I think the extra reason why she's devastated is that she knows how Darnley's murder is going to land across Europe. This is going to be seen by the crowned heads of Christendom as regicide, which they obviously view as being a terrible crime. They rank him as a king even though he isn't one. He's married to a queen. I mean, he's not officially a king, but they will see it as effectively being regicide. And she knows that one person who will be absolutely appalled is her royal cousin, Elizabeth
不仅如此，而且我认为她感到崩溃的另一个原因是，她知道达利的死讯在整个欧洲会带来怎样的反响。整个基督教世界的君主们会将其视为弑君之罪，他们显然认为这是滔天大罪。他们把达利当作国王看待，尽管他并不是。他娶了一位女王。我的意思是，他不是官方意义上的国王，但他们会认为这实际上就是弑君。并且她知道，有一个人绝对会为此感到震惊，那就是她的皇家表姐、一直与她处于谈判中的英国的
of England, with whom she has been in negotiations. So that I think is the key point. The timing of Darnley's murder for Mary could not have been worse. So if Mary didn't authorize or prove the murder, then who did? Well, by early May, you remember, we've got this Englishman in Berwick. Yeah, this guy, Sir William Drury, he thinks he has cracked the case. And so he writes to Cecil and he names the two leading culprits. And probably the name of these two leading culprits will not come as a surprise to listeners.
伊丽莎白。所以我想这才是关键所在。对于玛丽来说，达利遇害的时机简直不能再糟了。因此，如果玛丽没有授意或默许这起谋杀，那又是谁干的呢？好吧，到了5月初，大家还记得吧，我们在伯威克有一位这样的英国人。是的，这家伙，威廉·德鲁里爵士，他认为他已经破案了。于是他写信给塞西尔，并点出了两个主要的罪魁祸首。这两个主要罪魁祸首的名字大概不会让听众感到意外。
Morton, Drury writes, is noted to have assured friendship to Bothwell, which to be the thankfuller now for his favor showed him in his absence and trouble, he intended to continue. And this is a brilliant piece of detective work. Most people think that Bothwell and Morton are deadly enemies. They'd been on opposed sides in the the embroilio around the murder of Ritcio. But actually, what Drury has found out is that it was Bothwell who had pushed Mary to pardon Morton.
德鲁里写道，人们注意到莫顿向博斯韦尔保证了友谊，为了感谢博斯韦尔在他缺席和陷入麻烦时对他的关照，他打算继续保持这份友谊。这是一项出色的侦探工作。大多数人都认为博斯韦尔和莫顿是死敌。在围绕里佐谋杀案的纷争中，他们曾站在对立的立场上。但事实上，德鲁里发现的是，正是博斯韦尔敦促玛丽赦免了莫顿。
And the reason that he had done that was because Bothwell knew that even though he'd been opposed to Morton over the Ritzio plot, any resentment that Morton might feel towards Bothwell is as nothing compared to the utter loathing that Morton has for Darnley, who had double crossed him over the Ritzio plot. And so Bothwell and Morton and Maitland as well had met up on the 14th of January and they had had discussions. And we left it hanging in the previous half, what were these discussions about? Well, Drury has found out what these discussions were about.
他之所以这么做，是因为博斯韦尔知道，尽管他曾在里佐谋杀案中与莫顿对立，但莫顿对博斯韦尔可能怀有的任何怨恨，与莫顿对达利的刻骨仇恨相比都微不足道，因为达利在里佐谋杀案中出卖过他。因此，博斯韦尔、莫顿以及梅特兰（Maitland）也在1月14日会面并进行了讨论。我们在上一半节目中留下了悬念，这些讨论是关于什么的呢？好吧，德鲁里已经查明了这些讨论的内容。
They were committing themselves to the murder of Darnley. Very rapidly, they had succeeded in signing up large numbers of other prominent Scottish nobles. What had motivated all of them, so Morton is obviously motivated by personal resentment, but the number of people who were prepared to sign up to the murder of Darnley reflects the fact that he is seen as a massive, massive problem to be eliminated. And it's very telling, for instance, that one of the conspirators seems to have been the lead of Trakair, who was the man who had witnessed Darnley's terrible behavior at his house.
他们承诺要谋杀达利。非常迅速地，他们成功拉拢了大量其他显赫的苏格兰贵族。是什么激励了所有人呢？莫顿显然是出于个人怨恨，但愿意参与谋杀达利的人数反映出一个事实，即达利被视为一个必须被消灭的巨大、巨大的麻烦。这非常有说明意义，例如，其中一个阴谋者似乎是特拉克尔（Trakair）领主，他正是那个目睹了达利在他宅邸里恶劣行为的人。
Yeah. Darnley's residence in Kirk of Fields provide the conspirators with the perfect opportunity. But of course, the moment he leaves Kierkefield and goes back to Mary, it then becomes much harder to eliminate him without also killing Mary, which they don't want to do. And Bothwell, who has been in close attendance on Mary throughout, I mean, he's absolutely keeping abreast of Darnley's potential movements. And so that's why it's the night before he's due to leave that they realize, well, we've got to go for it. It is also Bothwell who supplies the gun powder
是的。达利在教会旷野的住所为阴谋者提供了绝佳的机会。但当然，一旦他离开基克菲尔德回到玛丽身边，要想在不杀死玛丽的情况下消灭他就变得困难得多，而这是他们不想做的。博斯韦尔一直密切陪伴在玛丽身边，我的意思是，他绝对随时掌握着达利潜在的行动动向。所以这就是为什么就在他预定离开的前一天晚上，他们意识到，好吧，我们必须动手了。也是博斯韦尔提供了火药
for the explosion, and he can do that because he is the sheriff of Edinburgh, and so people would expect to see him in charge of men who were kind of, you know, rumbling through the streets of Edinburgh with wagons or whatever. So on the evening of the 9th of February, as Mary and Darnley are partying in the rooms above them, Morton's men are mining the cellars of the house. And in fact, Mary runs into one of these people. He'd been a page of Bothwell. He's now become a valet to Mary and he has the nickname of French Paris. And Mary sees him and says, Jesus Paris, how
用于爆炸，他之所以能做到这一点，是因为他是爱丁堡的郡长，所以人们看到他指挥那些拉着大车穿梭在爱丁堡街头或干别的什么事的人，会觉得是理所当然的。因此，在2月9日傍晚，当玛丽和达利在他们头顶的房间里聚会时，莫顿的手下正在挖掘房子的地窖。事实上，玛丽碰巧遇到了其中一个人。他曾是博斯韦尔的一个侍童，现在成为了玛丽的贴身男仆，人们给他起了个绰号叫“法国巴黎”（French Paris）。玛丽看到他并说道：“天哪，巴黎，你怎么
begrimed you are. Oh, what a thing to say to somebody. I mean, mad. His face is streaked, but Mary can see through the dirt that he is blushing. But he says nothing, just twists his cap. How begrimed you are. I'd like to use that. I'm going to use that line.
弄得这么满脸污垢。”哦，对别人说这样的话。我的意思是，太疯狂了。他的脸上有条纹，但玛丽透过灰尘能看出他在脸红。但他什么也没说，只是扭弄着自己的帽子。“你怎么弄得这么满脸污垢。”我想用这句话。我要用这句台词。
You can use it to Arthur, surely. If he's... I will. Well, he's always begrimed, to be fair. What I don't understand, right, I get the explosion, begrimed people have mined this building and it's blown up. What I don't get is why Darnley didn't die in the explosion. Why is he lying in the garden next to a chair, a rope and a cloak? Are the Freemasons involved in some peculiar way before being founded? Yeah, this is the whole Agatha Christie dimension to it, which is always so intrigued and fascinated
你当然可以用它来对付亚瑟。如果他……我会的。好吧，说句公道话，他总是灰头土脸的。我不明白的是，对吧，我懂爆炸，满脸污垢的人挖了这个建筑并把它炸毁了。我不明白的是为什么达利没有在爆炸中死掉？为什么他躺在椅子、绳子和斗篷旁边的花园里？难道共济会在它成立之前就以某种奇特的方式参与其中了吗？是的，这正是整个阿加莎·克里斯蒂式的悬疑维度，它总是让人着迷和着迷，
people and I think complicated attempts to solve the murder. Guy's explanation, which is essentially a refinement of the reports that Drury has been sending to Cecil. So I think Drury is the guy who really nails it. Drury reports to Cecil that on the night of Darnley's murder, he suspects nothing of what is to come. He makes his farewells to Mary and then he goes to bed. And shortly afterwards, he's woken by the sounds of muffled footsteps from below. He looks out of a side window and he sees kind of shadowy cloaked figures stealthily moving around. He is a guy who knows he has lots of enemies.
并且我认为这使破案的尝试变得更加复杂。盖伊的解释本质上是对德鲁里发给塞西尔的报告的提炼。所以我认为德鲁里才是真正破案的人。德鲁里向塞西尔报告说，在达利遇害当晚，他对即将发生的事情毫无察觉。他向玛丽告别，然后上床睡觉。不久之后，他被下方传来的沉闷脚步声惊醒。他向侧窗外望去，看到一些披着斗篷的可疑身影在鬼鬼祟祟地移动。他是一个知道自己有很多敌人的人。
He assumes the worst and he reaches for a thick fur cloak. He then wakes his valet and other servants and he goes to a window that looks directly out over the city wall, which kind of adjoins the house in which he's in. The servants get a chair and they tie a rope to this chair and they then lower Darnley and his valet into the street below, so outside the city wall. However, disaster. Drury's greatest investigative achievement has been to identify what happens next and in particular to identify the man who had been on patrol in the street in case of just such an eventuality. And this is a guy we've already met. He's a bloke called Andrew Kerr of Falden side and he was the man who in the course of the Rizzio murder had pointed a loaded gun at
他做最坏的打算，伸手去拿一件厚重的毛皮斗篷。然后他叫醒了他的男仆和其他仆人，走到一个可以直接俯瞰城墙的窗户前，那道城墙毗邻他所在的房子。仆人们搬来一把椅子，将一根绳子系在椅子上，然后把达利和他的男仆降到下面的街道上，也就是城墙外面。然而，灾难发生了。德鲁里最伟大的调查成就是查明了接下来发生了什么，特别是认出了那个当时正在街头巡逻、以防万一发生这种意外情况的人。这就是我们已经见过的一个家伙。他叫安德鲁·克尔（Andrew Kerr of Falden side），他就是在里佐谋杀案中把上膛的枪
Mary's pregnant belly. He as one of the Rizio conspirators is as consumed with hatred for Darnley as Morton and like Morton is absolutely set on getting his revenge and this is despite the fact that Darnley is actually a kinsman of Andrew Kerr. And to this end, Kerr, like Morton, has teamed up with Bothwell. Andrew writes to Cecil in details what happened next. The King was long of dying and to his strengths made debate for his life, which essentially means that he had tried to reason with Kerr and his men. And this report is substantiated in a remarkable way by the testimony of old women who lived in cottages on the side of this road and who were interrogated by agents of the Scottish
顶在玛丽怀孕肚皮上的那个人。作为里佐谋杀案的阴谋者之一，他对达利的恨意与莫顿不相上下，和莫顿一样，他绝对铁了心要报仇，尽管事实上达利其实是安德鲁·克尔的亲戚。为了达到这个目的，克尔和莫顿一样，与博斯韦尔联手了。安德鲁详细地写信给塞西尔，描述了接下来发生的事情。“国王死得很慢，并凭借自己的体力为生命做了一番抗争，”这基本上意味着他曾试图与克尔及其手下讲道理。这份报告得到了惊人的证实，证实来自于住在路边小屋里的老妇人们的证词，她们受到了苏格兰
Privy Council. And one of these women reported hearing Darnley cry out, Oh, my kinsman, have mercy on me for the love of him who had mercy on all the world. But it's no good. Darnley and his valet are both strangled, so that's why there are no marks on their bodies. And then they are taken and laid out in a neighbouring garden and the chair, the rope and the cloak are dumped beside them. Now, the issue obviously is Darnley is dead, so do they need to blow up the house? the problem is that there might be all kinds of evidence they don't really want the gun powder to be found because then the lead might go back to both well so they think i will let's blow it up anyway so that's what they do. The fact that you have this kind of, you know, the chair and the rope and everything in the garden and the explosion is what has made it such an enduring and tantalising mystery
枢密院特工的审讯。其中一位妇人报告说听到达利大喊：“哦，我的亲戚，看在对世人施以怜悯的那位的分上，饶了我吧！”但无济于事。达利和他的男仆都被勒死了，这就是为什么他们的尸体上没有任何伤痕。然后他们被带到一个相邻的花园里摆放好，椅子、绳子和斗篷被扔在他们旁边。现在，问题显然是达利已经死了，那他们还有必要炸毁房子吗？问题在于可能会留下各种证据，他们其实不想让火药被找到，因为那样线索可能会顺藤摸瓜找到博斯韦尔头上，所以他们想，管他呢，不管怎样我们还是把它炸了吧，于是他们就这样做了。事实上，你把这种椅子、绳子以及花园里的种种东西和爆炸结合在一起，正是这起谋杀案变得如此持久且引人入胜的谜团所在，也是人们如此难以破案的原因。但我觉得盖伊在他书中给出的那个解答，在我看来似乎是对所发生事情最合理的解释。
and why it's been so hard for people to solve. But I think that that solution that Guy gives in his book, I mean, it seems to me the likeliest explanation for what actually happened. So it's not a ritualistic killing and it's not been designed that way. No, it's just the result of him having tried to escape and this bloke Kerr kind of finding him. So they strangled him. Why didn't they just stab him?
所以这不是一场仪式性的谋杀，也不是那样设计出来的。不，这只是他试图逃跑却被这个叫克尔的家伙撞见的后果。所以他们勒死了他。他们为什么不直接捅死他呢？
That worked with Ritio. Why the strangulation? That's my question. I suppose to make his death seem as mysterious as possible to kind of throw people off the scent. And also you just want to mix things up a bit. You don't want to just use the same method every time. Yeah, exactly. They've already done the whole stabbing stuff.
对里佐就是那么干的。为什么要勒死？这是我的问题。我猜是为了让他的死看起来尽可能神秘，从而转移人们的视线。而且你就是想换换花样。你不想每次都用同样的方法。是的， exatamente。他们已经玩过捅人的把戏了。
Right. Yeah. Try something different. I mean, what would it be brilliant if they'd had kind of 56 stab wounds like with Rizzio, but yeah, yeah, but no. All right. So a couple of questions that are still hanging. Number one, is it plausible that as Elizabeth sort of suggested in that letter, that
对。是的。尝试点别的。我的意思是，如果他们像对里佐那样捅了56刀，那会不会很精彩，但是，是的，是的，并没有。好吧。那么还有几个悬而未决的问题。第一，伊丽莎白在信中某种程度上暗示的那种说法是否合理，即
Mary had been looking through her fingers at the deed that she, okay, maybe she didn't officially authorise it formally, but maybe she kind of knew that it was in the air and she just gave them a little wink or she just, or she did nothing. She knew it was coming, but she did nothing to stop it. Well, it's a very good question. And we know of someone who did exactly that and this is the Earl of Moray, whom Maitland, in a very suggestive prefiguring of Elizabeth's use of the same phrase in her letter to Mary, had correctly predicted that although he wouldn't participate
玛丽对这起行径睁一只眼闭一只眼，她，好吧，也许她没有正式、官方地授权，但也许她隐约知道这事正在酝酿，她只是给他们使了个眼色，或者她什么也没做。她知道事情要发生，但她什么也没做去阻止它。这是一个非常好的问题。我们认识一个正是这么做的人，这就是莫瑞伯爵（Earl of Moray）。梅特兰曾对伊丽莎白在写给玛丽的信中使用相同短语进行过非常暗示性的预言，他准确地预测到，尽管莫瑞不会参与针对达利的阴谋，但他会对谋杀的筹备工作睁一只眼闭一只眼。换句话说，他会给予默许和眼色。基本上，莫瑞知道会发生什么，但他没有通知玛丽。相反，由于意识到事情正走向白热化，他离开了爱丁堡，退守到法夫（Fife）的领地上，这样他就可以说：“看，这跟我没关系，老兄。”相比之下，玛丽当然，她把达利遇害前的整个晚上用来，你知道的，在一个到处塞满火药的房子里聚会，在我看来，这是一个非常有力的间接证据，证明她对这起罪行
in the plot against Darnley, he would look through his fingers at preparations for the murder. So in other words, he would give it a nod and a wink. Basically, Moray knew what was going to happen and he didn't inform Mary. And instead, aware that things were coming to a head, he had absented himself from Edinburgh and retreated to his estate in Fife so that he could say, look, nothing to do with me, mate. Mary, of course, by contrast, I mean, she spends the evening before Darnley's murder, you know, partying in a house that is absolutely packed with gunpowder, which seems to me a very strong circumstantial piece of evidence that she knew
一无所知。而且当你读到安东尼娅·弗雷泽（Antonia Fraser）关于玛丽温柔内心的记述时，也隐隐透出一丝滑稽。多么善良的人啊。你知道，我认为那是对的。事实上，我的意思是，从你的角度来看，我想象也是如此。
nothing whatsoever of the crime. And also there was a slight hint of amusement when you read Antonia Fraser's account of Mary's tender heart. Such a kind person. You know, I think that's right. And in fact, I mean, you know, from your perspective, I would imagine. Yeah. That's part of the problem with Mary. She is too tender hearted.
那是玛丽的问题的一部分。她太心慈手软了。如果你不打算认真玩，就别玩这个游戏。
Don't play the game unless you're going to play it properly. Yeah. Exactly. That's my take on history generally. I think the conspirators feel like you do. That's why they don't tell her. That's why they don't even hint at it because they're worried that she might step in and say, no, you're not allowed to do this. And I think also another key piece of evidence that Mary
是的。完全正确。这就是我对历史的普遍看法。我认为阴谋者们的感受和你一样。这就是为什么他们不告诉她。这就是为什么他们甚至不暗示这一点，因为他们担心她可能会介入并说：“不，你们不能这么做。”我认为另一个关键证据是，玛丽
didn't do it is her evident panic when she is told that Darnley had been killed because she does genuinely, it seems to me, she's very, very worried that she had been the target. So as Guy puts it, Mary was a good actress, but not this good. So all of that, I think, kind of adds up to absolve Mary of the crime. But just to reiterate, the key piece of evidence, I think, is that the timing for her is terrible in relation to her negotiations with Elizabeth, because she has everything to lose and actually in the event she does, because that letter from Elizabeth, which we began this episode with, I mean, it's a warning shot across Mary's bow as it's saying essentially, you know, solve the crime, arraign those who
并没有参与其中，那就是当她被告知达利被杀时她那明显的恐慌，因为在我看来，她确实是真心地非常、非常担心自己成了目标。正如盖伊所说：“玛丽是个好演员，但没好到这种程度。”所以这一切，在我看来，都足以洗脱玛丽的罪名。但再次重申，关键的证据我认为是，对她而言，这个时机在她与伊丽莎白的谈判中实在是糟透了，因为她拥有一切可以失去的，而事实上最终她也确实失去了，因为伊丽莎白的那封信——也就是我们本集节目开头提到的那封信——对玛丽来说是一个警告信号，基本上是在说，你知道的，破案，把那些
are responsible for it or else there's no way that you are going to be my heir. Does Mary solve the crime? The answer, I guess, is no. And this is disastrous for Mary. Yeah. And her failure to do that results, I mean, in her total ruin. And that, of course, leads to the second puzzle, which is why doesn't she manage to solve the crime? Because as we know, there are very detailed and effective investigations. There are people from the Privy Council who are interviewing the old women and taking down their records.
应负责任的人绳之以法，否则你绝不可能成为我的继承人。玛丽破案了吗？我想答案是没有。这对玛丽来说是灾难性的。是的。而她未能做到这一点，意味着——她的彻底毁灭。当然，这就引出了第二个谜团，那就是为什么她没能破案？因为如我们所知，有非常详细且高效的调查。有枢密院的人在走访老妇人并记录她们的证词。
There's a jury's report that's gone to Cecil. Why aren't these being collated and publicized rather than, as actually happens, being suppressed and in lots of cases completely forgotten? And the answer again, I think, is pretty obvious. It's because those who commissioned these reports had every interest in suppressing them because the Privy Council, I mean, is absolutely full of people who had actually been responsible for Darnley's murder. So Bothwell, Morton, Maitland, and of those three, Bothwell, Morton, Maitland, two in particular have a real reason to lie low and allow the rumour to do its work because one of those three is being fingered for the crime.
有一份提交给塞西尔的陪审团报告。为什么这些没有被整理并公之于众，反而如实际发生的那样被压制，并在很多情况下被彻底遗忘呢？答案再次我认为相当明显。那是因为委任这些报告的人有着充分的动机去压制它们，因为枢密院，我的意思是，里面全都是实际对达利谋杀案负有责任的人。所以博斯韦尔、莫顿、梅特兰，在这三个人当中，博斯韦尔、莫顿、梅特兰，其中有两个人有着真正的理由保持低调，并任由谣言四处流传，因为这三个人中有一个人正被指控为罪魁祸首。
And so the other two can say, well, let's lie low and let him take the blame. And the person who is being fingered for it is Bothwell. And accusations against Bothwell are starting to be laid within a week of Darnley's murder by his father, the Earl of Lennox. Placards and graffiti and cartoons start to appear across the streets of Edinburgh charging Bothwell directly with the murder kind of caricatures of Bothwell start appearing on buildings and They have the label here is the murder of the king
所以另外两个人就可以说，好吧，让我们保持低调，让他来背黑锅吧。而那个正被指控的人就是博斯韦尔。在达利遇害后的一周内，博斯韦尔的父亲伦诺克斯伯爵（Earl of Lennox）就开始针对博斯韦尔提出指控。爱丁堡的街头开始出现标语、涂鸦和漫画，直接指控博斯韦尔谋杀，博斯韦尔的讽刺画开始出现在建筑物上，
And this of course is very bad news for Bothwell but it is also very very bad news for Mary because also very, very bad news for Mary because rumors have been swirling throughout Scotland long before Darnley's murder that Mary has got a real crush on Bothwell. And some of the evidence for this is bogus. So for instance, the story that she had ridden alone to the Hermitage when Bothwell had been stabbed, that wasn't true. But the fact the story was told is suggestive of how the trend of gossip is going. And some of the stories are true. So for instance, Mary had given Bothwell a
上面写着标签：“国王的谋杀者在此”。这当然对博斯韦尔来说是个坏消息，但对玛丽来说同样也是非常、非常坏消息，因为早在达利遇害之前，整个苏格兰就一直在流传着谣言，说玛丽对博斯韦尔迷恋至极。其中一些证据是伪造的。例如，她曾独自骑马去埃尔米蒂奇（Hermitage）看望受伤的博斯韦尔的故事，那并不是真的。但这个故事被讲述的事实表明了八卦的走向。而且有些故事是真的。例如，玛丽曾送给博斯韦尔一套
spectacular blue suit at the christening and she had kind of basically employed Bothwell to take the place of Darnley, her husband, who had refused to attend. So you can kind of see how these rumors, they have legs. And because of that, it doesn't take long for graffiti to start appearing on the walls of Edinburgh charging that not only is Bothwell guilty of Darnley's murder, but Mary is as well. And what about the English dimension to this, Tom? Because we started the whole episode with Elizabeth the First letter. What about Elizabeth and her Chief Minister Cecil?
极其华丽的蓝色西装，在洗礼仪式上，她基本上安排了博斯韦尔来代替拒绝出席的她的丈夫达利。所以你可以看出这些谣言是如何不胫而走的。正因如此，没过多久，爱丁堡的墙壁上就开始出现涂鸦，指控不仅博斯韦尔有罪，玛丽也同样有罪。那么关于这其中的英国因素呢，汤姆？因为我们整集节目都是以伊丽莎白一世的信件开头的。伊丽莎白和她的首席大臣塞西尔对此怎么看？
What do they make of all this? Are they preparing to use this against Mary effectively, sort of cynically? Cecil definitely. We've been talking throughout this series how Cecil is Mary's great hidden enemy. He's actively working to stop Mary succeeding to the English throne, but also he's pretty keen on toppling Mary from her own throne. And so he sees a huge opportunity here. Why on earth would he publish anything that might help to absolve Mary? And I think definitely he is kind of pouring poison into Elizabeth's ear. So remember that phrase, looking through fingers, that Maitland had applied to Moray and that Elizabeth writes in her letter to Mary. I
他们是如何看待这一切的？他们是否准备好有效地、某种程度上冷酷地利用这一点来对付玛丽？塞西尔绝对是的。我们在整个系列中一直在讨论塞西尔是玛丽最大的暗中敌人。他积极致力于阻止玛丽继承英国王位，而且他也非常热衷于将玛丽从她自己的王位上推翻下来。所以他在这里看到了一个巨大的机会。他怎么可能会去发表任何可能有助于洗脱玛丽罪名的东西呢？我绝对认为他是在往伊丽莎白的耳边灌输毒药。所以还记得那个短语吗，“睁一只眼闭一只眼”，梅特兰曾将它用在莫瑞身上，而伊丽莎白在写给玛丽的信中也使用了它。我
think it's very easy to imagine Cecil having dropped precisely that phrase into conversation with Elizabeth and Elizabeth then using it herself in her letter. And then there is that anonymous traitor whom Elizabeth referred to in her letter comparing him to the minister of Satan. She doesn't need to name him because it's so self-evidently Bothwell. Now you ask, does Elizabeth, like Cecil, want to see Mary ruined? No, she absolutely doesn't. Quite the opposite. So just to quote that letter again, I exhort you, I counsel you, and I beseech you to take this thing so much to heart that you will not fear to touch even him whom you have nearest to you if the thing touches him." What Elizabeth's trying to do is to help Mary safeguard her throne and not allow her reputation
很容易想象塞西尔正是把这个词组抛给了伊丽莎白进行对话，然后伊丽莎白便在自己的信中使用了它。接着还有伊丽莎白在信中提到的那个匿名叛徒，将其比作撒旦的仆从。她甚至不需要点名，因为那显然就是博斯韦尔。现在你可能会问，伊丽莎白是否像塞西尔一样，希望看到玛丽毁灭？不，她绝对不想。恰恰相反。所以再引用那封信的话：“我劝告你，我奉劝你，我恳求你把这件事如此放在心上，以至于你不会害怕去触动甚至是你最亲近的人，如果这件事涉及他个人的话。”伊丽莎白试图做的是帮助玛丽保住她的王位，不让她的声誉
to be torched by this devastating accumulation of hostile rumor of which two rumors in particular are the most lethal. One that she had joined with Bothwell in the plot to murder Darnley. And secondly, that she had done this out of an adulterous passion for Bothwell. And so Elizabeth is saying, for God's sake, you know, have nothing to do with Bothwell, arraign him, convict him, execute him. But the big question is, of course, will Mary listen to this self-evidently excellent advice? Well, Mary has a history in this series of making very poor decisions.
被这毁灭性的充满敌意的谣言累积所摧毁，其中有两个谣言尤为致命。一是她与博斯韦尔合谋谋杀达利。二是她出于对博斯韦尔的通奸激情而做出了这一切。所以伊丽莎白在说，看在上帝的份上，你知道的，跟博斯韦尔划清界限，控告他，定罪他，处决他。但最大的问题当然是，玛丽会听取这个显然极好的建议吗？好吧，玛丽在这个系列中有着做出糟糕决策的前科。
So next time we will discover whether she redeems herself and makes the right choice or whether things get even darker for her. Now the only way to listen to that episode right now, because I imagine most people are gagging to find out the answer, the only way to do it is to join our own murderous conspiracy, The Rest Is History Club, at therestishistory.com. If you do that, you can hear right away what happened next in this extraordinary story. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以下次我们将探讨她是否能自我救赎并做出正确的选择，还是说事情会为她变得更加黑暗。现在，收听那一集的唯一方法——因为我猜大多数人都在迫切想知道答案——唯一的办法就是加入我们自己的谋杀阴谋组织，即《历史其余部分》俱乐部，网址是 therestishistory.com。如果你那样做了，你就可以立即听到这个非凡故事接下来的发展。再见。再见。本集节目尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。